[Musik]
musik tanzen dicht an sich würde james
last
aber das wäre doch schön dass sie
letztendlich ja so fühlt sich das an in
dänemark beispielsweise oder in england
da ist das realität aber hier bei uns da
können wir nach wie vor nur davon
träumen claus strunz btv chef ist
hiermit bei uns im studio
würdest du in clubs gehen in dicht
gedrängte sowie die dänen und wie die
engländer und damit ans alte jedenfalls
komme ich da schon in stimmung und das
macht auch die temperatur und die
atmosphäre für diesen tag denn ich
glaube heute ist einer der wichtigsten
tage in der ganzen pandemie phase weil
heute jeder der klar nachdenkt zu der
erkenntnis kommen muss dass die zeit
reif ist die maßnahmen zu überwinden und
zu einem normalen leben zurückzukehren
wir haben ja heute eine große bild
schlagzeile gesehen die genau das
fordert und die argumentation die dem
zugrunde liegt ist so unwiderstehlich
dass sie es so zu sagen eigentlich
niemand dass sich niemand entziehen kann
ich will mal einen wichtigen vielleicht
den wichtigsten punkt voran schicken der
wichtigste punkt war ja immer es darf
das gesundheitssystem nicht kollabieren
dem hat sich außerdem hat sich alles
abgeleitet nur
gefühlskalten menschen könnten da was
dagegen haben wenn die krankenhäuser
überfüllt sind wenn die
intensivstationen nicht mehr klarkommen
wenn menschen sterben müssen weil keine
plätze in krankenhäusern da sind dann
muss gehandelt werden ehrlich gesagt so
war es in deutschland nie aber die sorge
davor hat all diese maßnahmen in kraft
gesetzt jetzt ist aber das gegenteil der
fall die krankenhäuser haben sie im
griff dank der tollen arbeit aller
menschen die dort arbeiten
dank der logistischen planung dank
einiger maßnahmen die es gibt und jetzt
ist der tag da wo wir sagen müssen wenn
das wichtigste argument nicht mehr
greift dann schauen wir uns auch alles
andere an und dann gehen wir in eine
wiedergewonnene freiheit und wie
verrückt das schon ist dass man sich auf
die freiheit wieder freut ich habe immer
gedacht wir leben in einem freien land
jetzt muss schluss sein mit den
einschränkungen und alle maßnahmen
müssen schritt für schritt fallen sagst
du dass heute der tag gesagt aber nicht
die politik wie lange dürfen wir das
noch mitmachen wie lange müssen wir das
noch mitmachen also ich hoffe nicht mehr
sehr lange ich glaube dass ich passe
mich jetzt was gar nicht meine art ist
mal der agenda der politik an nächste
woche seine mpk angekündigt für den 16
wenn ich richtig sie beginnt die woche
mit dem valentinstag also einem großen
tag der liebe dann lasst uns doch die
nächste woche zur freiheit woche machen
in deutschland und ich finde den begriff
freiheits woche liegt sogar sehr sehr
viel vernunft denn der freedom day den
allem ausrufen der passt nicht zu dem
dezentralen land mit vielen ländern mit
vielen bundesländern der passt eher zu
einem zentralistischen land lasst uns
eine woche erklären in der wir schritt
für schritt zurückkehren und der anfang
ist er schon gemacht in hessen ist zweig
im einzelhandel ja schon gefallen durch
eine gerichtsentscheidung und so muss
jetzt dominosteinen für domino stein
sozusagen der weg zurück in ein freies
leben in diesem land möglich werden karl
lauterbach gestern bei die richtigen
fragen hierbei bild tv hat ja auch
angedeutet deutlich vor ostern hat er
gesagt wird die freiheit zurückkommen
ostern ist glaube ich am 17 april oder
achtzehnter april das heißt anfang april
werde dass er gleichzeitig gesagt jetzt
im moment wäre es noch zu früh öl ins
feuer gießen so zu sagen und man könne
es nicht mit den engländern vergleichen
denn hier sind zwölf prozent der über 60
jährigen noch nicht geimpft in england
nur zwei prozent wir gucken mal rein was
karl lauterbach gestern bei die
richtigen fragen gesagt hat also wenn
ich sie so höre habe ich das gefühl sie
stehen da er auf der seite von den
kretschmann in baden-württemberg der
sagt vor ostern nichts lockern
herrn kretschmann habe ich mich nicht
ausgetauscht ich glaube dass wir vor
deutlich vor ostern lockern werden davon
bin ich fest überzeugt sind sie für
lockerungen oder dagegen über das kommt
da waren wie die fahrt zahlen sich jetzt
entwickeln jetzt im moment bin ich
dagegen so gehen davon aus dass immer
noch eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystem droht das zeigen die
modelle ganz klar also wenn wir es jetzt
laut werden wir das jetzt komplett
öffnen würden ja wenn wir im herbst dann
tatsächlich bekämen dann glaube ich ist
der spuk vorbei war das gehend weil wir
damit also die impflücken geschlossen
herr lauterbach ist ja normalerweise der
mist da vorsichtig und dann diese
aussage hatte ich das trotzdem
überrascht naja ich habe vor allem an
einer stelle genau hingehört weil er
bietet die ein tauschgeschäft an dass
wir auf keinen fall zulassen dürfen ein
tauschgeschäft lautet impfpflicht gegen
freiheit das ist das was er da sagt das
ist brandgefährlich weil mein plädoyer
und das plädoyer hinter euch auf den
großen schlagzeilen sagt ja wir brauchen
keine allgemeine impfpflicht und können
trotzdem lockern weil sich die
fallzahlen entwickeln wie sie sich eben
entwickeln weil omikron weniger
gefährlich ist als man vorher gedacht
hat weil die krankenhausbetten nicht
überlastet sind weil es sehr sehr sehr
sehr viele erkenntnisse gibt dass die
maßnahmen die jetzt ergriffen sind
ohnehin nicht wirklich wirken weil das
ausland uns vormacht dass man sozusagen
auf mut und vernunft setzen kann lasst
uns einmal noch ganz kurz innehalten und
sagen was war denn in deutschland los in
deutschland sind jetzt monate ja jahre
lang das team angst und vorsicht mit dem
team ratlos um die wette gelaufen angst
und vorsicht haben mit ratlos darüber
referiert und gekämpft und einen weg
macht angst vorsicht ratlosigkeit und
ich finde wir haben jetzt so viel
faktenbasis und so viel material und so
viel lebenserfahrung dazu gewonnen
dieser pandemie dass jetzt das team mut
mit dem team vernunft geschwindigkeit
aufnehmen muss und mit der gleichen mit
der gleichen begeistert heid mit dem
gleichen schmiss mit der gleichen
geschwindigkeit wie wir immer weiter
verschärft haben müssen wir jetzt
lockern lockern lockern es kann auch
nicht langsamer gehen wer jetzt noch auf
maximale sicherheit setzt muss ich mit
dem argument auseinandersetzen aber
vielleicht ein freiheits feindes
interessant ja auch bisher war es so
dass in der bevölkerung eine große
zustimmung zu den einschränkungen
geherrscht hat auch da scheint sich
jetzt eine trendwende abzuzeichnen wir
schauen mal auf eine grafik bild hat in
seiner gebeten eine meinungsumfrage zu
geben und da sieht man dass die mehrheit
jetzt für corona lockerungen
sind zweig im einzelnen 53 prozent sagen
dass zweig plus in der gastronomie 51%
kontakt beschränkung für geimpfte 66
prozent also die mehrheit will
lockerungen haben das ist eine deutliche
umkehr des trends die wir bisher gesehen
haben masken pflicht und beschränkungen
für ungeimpfte allerdings das wollen die
menschen weiter behalten
auch da können wir noch mal auf die
grafik schauen masken pflichten in
bussen und zügen da sein 71 das soll
weiterhin gelten masken pflicht im
einzelhandel 65% und akt beschränkungen
allerdings nur für ungeimpfte sagen 64
prozent die anderen maßnahmen sollen
abgeschafft franken natürlich auch warum
haben die menschen sich so sehr an diese
maske gewöhnte warum hängen diese an der
maske ja ich finde das gibt dir wieder
was wir gerade diskutiert haben nämlich
einen schritt für schritt als erstes
muss dieses unsinnige zweig im
einzelhandel und in der gastronomie weg
es ist ja völlig absurd dass es
situationen in deutschland sind wohl
jemand der nicht geimpftes ich übrigens
sagt lieber nicht geimpfte als
ungeimpfte weil für mein empfinden
steckt in dem der vorsilbe um eine
wertung drin unheil unrat in wahrheit
alles was mit uni anfängt ist irgendwie
negativ ich finde aber nicht geimpfte
menschen gar nicht so negativ die haben
halt für sich eine entscheidung
getroffen also es kann ja nicht sein
dass in der gastronomie ein nicht
geimpfter mit einem negativ test als
kellner arbeiten kann aber nach
dienstschluss kann im gleichen lokal
nicht essen gehen das ist ja also jemand
das kriegt man nicht erklärt oder auch
bizarre dinge im flugzeug steigt man
neuerdings reihe für reihe aus ja wer
jetzt im urlaub war das vielleicht
miterlebt reihe für reihe und dann steht
unten der bussteig an alle ein bus ein
so verrückt es gibt es ja gar nicht das
bedeutet all diese absurden absurden
regeln müssen weg und in einem zweiten
schritt müssen auch die ganzen masken
regeln die hier noch mit einer mehrheit
für sehen sind aus sorge das kann nicht
verstehen er diskutiert werden und weg
und dann würde ich es halt jedem selber
überlassen ob er eine maske trägt um
sich zu schützen oder ob er sie nicht
trägt 1 ist aber noch ganz wichtig und
das glaube ich kann man aus den zahlen
auch rauslesen weil die schon dafür ein
ganz gutes gespür haben wer heute an
corona stirbt oder einen maximal
schweren verlauf hat wird schon sich
auch der kritik ausgesetzt sehen müssen
ob man nicht dazu beigetragen hat weil
er sich nicht impfen lassen die
allermeisten die heute einen schweren
verlauf kriegen sind ungeübte nicht
geimpfte die für sich eine entscheidung
getroffen worden und jetzt wird man
sagen jaja wie kühl was sie redet der da
und ich kenne jemand der ein kennt der
einen kennt dessen bruder hat eine frau
und deren schwester die hätten einen
ganz schweren verlauf gehabt war aber
geimpft und da muss man dann einfach
auch als gesellschaft sagen das gehört
dann zu den allgemeinen lebensrisiken so
wie grippe an der auch jedes jahr leute
sterben sowie das einen baum auf den
kopf fällt wenn es stürmt und das glaube
ich ist der wichtige moment sich das
klar zu machen ansonsten nehmen wir
dieses land noch über monate und jahre
und wir dürfen wir eines nicht vergessen
es sind ja bereits jetzt 350 milliarden
euro an kosten entstanden durch die
pandemie jeder der einigermaßen bei
droste stellt sich die frage wer bezahlt
es denn eigentlich und ich glaube dass
viele leute gerne für etwas bezahlen was
sie für sinnvoll halten und viele
maßnahmen waren in der pandemie
jedenfalls für die mehrheit
nachvollziehbar und sinnvoll also auch
mit dem eigenen geld denn man muss es
war unser geld wird es sein das geld
unserer zuschauer mit dem das bezahlt
wird über steuern über abgaben am ende
kommt doch noch ein pandemie so leven
kassensturz macht wir alle werden das
bezahlen das ist so lange okay wie die
maßnahmen verhältnismäßig und angemessen
sind ich hatte da oft schon meine
bedenken habe akzeptiert dass eine
mehrheit der menschen ist gut fand jetzt
finde ich ist der moment erreicht wo man
sagen muss weg damit die
verhältnismäßigkeit fehlt und die
sinnhaftigkeit fehlt und wenn beides
fehlt ist der tag gekommen an dem die
maßnahmen fallen müssen und zwar in der
liebes woche am valentinstag geht es
nicht schön waren uns zurück erinnern
würden es war
in der woche die mit dem valentinstag
begann und der innerlichen endlich hätte
der valentinstag dann weil
denn außer der geschäftemacherei obst
deshalb ich nicht wirklich romantische
vorstellung die meinung von klaus
dagegen dank klaus